good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning
toast happy tuesday that feels like a
monday but it is actually a tuesday
thank you president's day for giving us
the day off we are so grateful and
internally indebted to you
thank you so much what a beautiful long
weekend what a beautiful short week we
actually have such an exciting week
here at the toast like we just have so
much excitement going on
aside from the fact that it's a short
week which is always just a beautiful
thing
it's so stunning and i don't want to
jinx it but we've been having quite a
few
long weeks short weeks recently because
we had mlk day
we had president's day we had to
quarantine so we ended up like working
we had the snow day
the snow day and then we also went to
quarantine for like two days like a few
weeks ago so like
it like they've just been like sneaking
in on us into our lifestyle and i'm so
grateful i'm so happy to have them so
happy that they're here but also so
happy to be back at the show because i
feel like we have so much to talk about
we actually have some really great
stories today
and just the beautiful long weekend just
gave me so much joy de vivre
uh the joan de vivre is so real it's
through the roof
i mean honestly you guys we you know in
in the interest of being transparent
this is our second time starting the
show this morning right there's some
crazy ass construction going on outside
i actually went downstairs and just you
know surveilled
the block and i think we saw dorinda by
the way when we were outside i forgot to
tell you i'm like almost like i'm almost
100 sure i saw dorinda
um i just and i asked the lovely
gentlemen when they were going to be
done and they said about 20 minutes and
they didn't lie
yes it seems so far so good but it was
so loud we were in a wind turbine and we
just couldn't do that to you
so we had to start the show over um but
don't worry you didn't miss that much
club was just
sharing her fabulous indoor dining
experience well yes because i was saying
how
sunday um having valentine's day on a
sunday with monday being president's day
was such a premium experience it was
like the best valentine's day i think
i've ever had because it was just so
relaxed and me and ben
obviously were the last people on earth
to make dinner reservations so the only
time we could get at mastros was 5 45
which also ended up being just like
blessings on blessings like such a
lovely time to eat dinner we were out of
there by like
eight that's a long ass nobody know like
7 30.
sorry 7 30. and it was just like the
whole world was in front of us and we
went over to zach and liv's and we like
drank and played jeopardy
it was just so premium like i think that
we should try and have valentine's day
be on a sunday all the time
okay i mean it doesn't work that way but
i i like where your head's at
and it was my first experience indoor
dining by the way since they closed the
restaurants in new york they just opened
them
in time for valentine's day and it was
an experience
it was so are you now reinvigorated like
do you have plans every night this week
well i did
i've never been to the masters here in
the city i've been to one in arizona and
i just remember being swept away by
their butter cake and their bread basket
and i had an amazing time and i said to
ben like why don't we come here all the
time
it's so nice it was and you know it was
a great vibe too like there was just
like elegant and cool people all around
and i felt like this is where i was
meant to be and there you were
being being and of course i got like so
many not
you know let me not be dramatic like
four messages like
you are the reason my covet still exists
you
are covered and i'm like because i'm
eating at a restaurant that's legally
open
talk to cuomo if you have a problem
about it like leave me alone i'm just a
law-abiding
citizen over here that's literally crazy
people are still sending those messages
i just want to make sure everybody like
my instagram feed
is so post-pandemic i just want to make
sure everyone's getting those messages
yeah no i mean we definitely get like
crazy ass messages because we have
crazy ass stalker freak fans who well
who used to be fans
but they're fans they literally watch
everything that we do some of them even
pay for patreon like to see what we're
doing yeah no it's like
sweetie you're a fan it's okay um no and
we have like a crazy level of like hater
fans
um so i know we get like above average
messages but like
we're doing the least like i'm literally
going to a restaurant wearing a mask and
just sitting at a restaurant
and i see like so many influencers like
doing the most going to st bart's like
all these things
do they get messages too because like i
want to be left alone i have to imagine
that they do
just they're just pretending that they
don't which is a move that's what i
gotta do which is a move
yeah messages um i also spent so much of
my weekend on clubhouse i'm just
obsessed with clubs
i saw you were clubbing here you were
clubbing there i did some clubhouses
but don't you get like nervous that
you're in a chat and your mics on
and you don't know well i'm pretty good
about my mic but you never know who
they're going to invite up to the stage
no
no not that not when you're in a chat
and you're muting and unmeeting like
that you opened your clubhouse and then
you happened
to like but it works no but like i'm
just
it makes me nervous sometimes that like
i'm accidentally like talking
well yeah like i turned i left a room
last night to go to bed it was like a
jersey shore themed room
at a reality tv i saw you in it but i
couldn't join because i had my night
guards in and i would have had a lisp
um but so then like i put it down and me
and ben were like you know just talking
and like you know
talking turns into talking [__] and i'm
like wait let me just check my clubhouse
that's what i'm saying yeah no the the
whole concept of like recording
it's weird but i i enjoy it so much i
also joined a toaster event last night
it was toasters with no job there was
like 200 toasters just like talking
about how much they love the toast and
then i joined and it was like
amazing oh my god they posted in toast
after dark they were doing it
i saw that there was something but i
just i couldn't get my stuff together
it was really fun wow that really sounds
amazing i'll have to join the next one
we did some other clubhouses this week
and we did karaoke which was really
funny that was probably my favorite one
that i did this weekend
hosted by cody co and his girlfriend
kelsey who is a toaster
and lauren was in there me and you and
it was just hysterical i
actually really liked that concept he
did had people come up onto the stage
for one second sing their heart out and
then kick them off it was really funny
it was really funny that was really fun
i'm loving the app i feel like the
toasters are getting into it too i think
that there
there's unlimited potential i'm loving
the app yeah like
it's so fun very cool space i've been
trying to like enter
like other clubhouses where they're
having like interesting meaningful
conversations
i haven't stumbled on the right one yet
but i'm trying i've stumbled on two so
far let me tell you one i saw
because kelty was on one so she had
found it that i need to follow her yeah
she cause she's great at finding rooms
it was all just about podcasting and
like me and kelty like
ran that [__] you know you know i'm
saying like that's cool too but like
also just to be an audience member and
like like
you know listening to some people's
minds no not to be annoying but like
every time i join like someone invites
me up and sometimes and this is what i
was gonna say i wanted to say this on
the toast today
if there is a person who works at
clubhouse and just wants some like
really good user feedback i have a lot
of ideas
i do think you should be able to watch
like on dark mode no one can see that
you're in there but you're listening i
agree
because i wanted to do that last night
with your chat i would have invited you
up 100
of me and my night guards yeah so it's
just i think there should be like an
invisible way of interacting
and i also think that you should be able
to block people because where is that
feature
no i think that you can i went to go
block someone and i couldn't
oh i heard that you could maybe i
couldn't keep looking okay
but i do have ideas so like get out get
back to me because the toasters are a
great like beta
testing group yeah yeah i think they're
doing some data testing i think that
they like have their stuff
together you know i just have ideas but
because also the thing with night mode
is you could be lurking
so i think they want accountability yeah
which i also like
right another um conversation i joined
was like with all these italians
vinnie i keep getting invited because of
vinnie and it was like the conversation
is new york city dead and there's
people from all different parts of the
city the bronx staten island just
conversing about like what it's been
like in new york and that was actually a
really interesting conversation what was
the consensus
well i was you know the token pessimist
but i'm also a realist and i'm just like
a lot of people were saying you know
like so many people gave up on new york
like moving to florida and i'm like i
just don't think it's fair for you to
like say someone's giving up on new york
like
they have families and like lives and
jobs and they're just doing what's best
for them and like it's been so hard to
live in new york this past year hasn't
been new york hasn't given anything to
us so i don't blame people who left
and i actually really think i changed a
lot of minds nice yes
nice but it was just fun and like i felt
like real italian and it's like okay
they gave up on new york but they're
living happy full lives in florida while
new york unhappy people you gave up like
okay i want to say something really
really
really controversial go ahead being like
you know in love with new york and like
new york strong like all this stuff like
that is not a personality trait i said
it like
it's just not like you can be a cool
person and like admit like new york is
deeply flawed yes but i just feel like
there's like a cat it's like the carrie
bradshaw thing
but new york like those types of people
like
not a personality trait yeah i think
that's a fair
assessment thank you so other than that
it was a great weekend yeah
yeah it was you know what i did this
weekend oh i did a number of things that
just
you know it was a domino effect of how
it affected my weekend but i went to a
barnes and noble and it was sensational
as you know you had said it and it was
true
and i was just like feeling so rdh
because i wanted to buy every single
book it's just everything looked so
stunning delectable and but of course i
read on my kindle so i wound up buying
two books that i didn't already have on
my kindle
because i had to i had to participate
yeah i bought firefly lane
i read it all weekend that was really
like my whole weekend because of the new
show on netflix and the book was really
good by the end i was getting kind of
over it it kind of dragged out but
overall really good i gave it four stars
and then i was gonna watch the show but
so many people who read the book said do
not watch the show
it's completely different from the book
they change so many things about the
story line
that will bother you and so i'm here to
say i won't be watching the show until
the book has left my mind like maybe in
a year i'll watch it um because
my personal opinion from reading the
book was like i hated
tully this doesn't mean anything to you
he's katherine heigl yes i hated her
character like
so so horribly selfish like irredeemable
and apparently with the changes in the
show like we like her
and that's just not what i'm wanting to
watch right now
interesting well i watched the third
installment up to all the boys i loved
before it just came out
how was and i just have to say like it
wasn't amazing but it's just so pleasant
to watch
and i know i've gone into my whole you
know theory on to all the boys i love
before verse the kissing booth a million
times
but even though it wasn't like the best
movie i'd ever seen it was like very
cliche like college what are we gonna do
it was i just love them like i love the
i love the setting i love john corbett i
love lana condor i love noah
i just think like everything about it
works so well
kids and by the end i was like literally
getting choked up that's so beautiful
was it better than two
yes i was not into the whole you know
love triangle in number two yeah but at
the end of the day like the movie is
well done the music is so good i just
love like all like of
you know um lara jean's like room like
it's just so well put together yeah
that it's just like a fun thing to watch
mindlessly okay i have to add that
to my plate i've really gotten back into
reading i have one thing to say
what two they did lara jean
dirty in this movie with some of her
wardrobe choices her prom dress
atrocious okay and part of the reason
why i loved her character so much in the
beginning was she such a great
style style yes they did her dirty
larging of movie one would
never have worn lara jean of movie
three's prom dress i have to see it now
and the other thing was the first this
was the first movie where i really felt
like her
and noah noah moore were a little too
old to be high school seniors like
yeah but other than that it was just
like really fun and fresh and if you're
looking for something just to like watch
mindlessly it's excellent
okay good to know yeah i'm i'm gonna put
that on my content plate i think bruno
will really like it
and then speaking of watching bruno can
watch three even though he didn't see
one and two yes
they they kind of give you backstory in
the beginning he'll be he'll be john
corbett has like a bigger
role than ever and i just love him
because he's getting married
oh okay yeah it was in the trailer sorry
i don't know if i just spoiled that for
you it's okay
um and then also speaking of watching
this is our third week of doing toast
movie
movie of the week in honor of black
history month and i am so excited we
literally planned this out two weeks ago
because we knew that the the version of
cinderella rogers and hammerstein's
version with whitney houston and brandy
would be going on to disney plus
february 12th so it is now on disney
plus
and that is what we are watching this
week i haven't seen it in
forever i think once when like we used
to live in long island like
so long yeah and i've heard i've
listened to the soundtrack a million
times i'm just so excited i heard
it's been restored renewed for the big
screen
and i cannot wait wow i can't wait
that's gonna be so fun to watch
wow that's exciting it's a good it's a
good choice it's a great content week
yes so it's streaming for free on disney
plus
and we'll chat about it on friday on
friday love it that was
our mini tv recap we obviously have the
bachelor recap at the end of today's
show
yes and shall we get into today's show
we have so many great stories like so
many disguises
so much so many things i'm looking to
get your opinion on yes one more thing i
need to
um i need to update you on because as
you know the warehouse has been
extremely sick
and they've actually taken medical
updates they've taken a turn for
the worse because these sweaters just
came in
the the crew neck is a bone color and
that font is a delicious
chocolate brown and this is literally
going to
slay the [__] out of your wardrobe how
you doing
available tomorrow morning at 10 a.m
eastern time
at shopmorningtoast.com as opposed to
shopper me says claudia clarified last
week yeah i know it's really confusing
it's
shop morning toast yes and there at 10
a.m tomorrow
will also be red heads merch i just
posted the whole redheads
line capsule collection on the redheads
instagram page so check that out if you
want to see
what's dropping yes and while a lot of
our products are unlimited this time
there are a few of the skus mostly the
apparel and the crewnecks
that are limited quantity so just make
sure
this color sweater is limited so if you
want to get what you want hop on as
early as you can some things are
unlimited but if you want to get exactly
what you want i would say
sign on early also in terms of sizing
i'm wearing a medium in this sweater
you'll notice when you get yours that
these sweaters all of the sweaters in
this drop are a little bit
thicker heartier than some of our other
sweaters so i
enjoyed sizing up usually i guess i
would wear a small but i don't know i
just need
i just need more any more coverage these
days i always wear an xl
in crewnecks and they nev the xl like
truly never lets me down
yeah so i toggle between a small and a
medium and if you two are a toggler
i would just go with the one up just
because i like the extra room
yeah but they're really warm if you're
in dallas right now
in that ice storm you need one of these
you do yeah really darn
and also i hope everyone's doing okay in
dallas yeah that was crazy
your in-laws your grandma lost power
right yes very crazy and it's all over
texas i thought people in austin were
also
um i saw crazy videos on tick tock i
know i saw i saw from people on
instagram stories i guess i follow a lot
of people who are in the texas area
um but these winter storms they're
coming fast and they're coming hard so
make sure you're hunkered down and you
have everything that you need yeah
seriously stay safe
stay safe i saw a terrible video of that
car pile up
oh my god oh my god it was crazy that
was so
crazy on i-35 in fort worth there was a
hundred car pile up
i saw the the cars were just flying it
was so
sad and so scary because each time a car
couldn't stop
so it's just going and going and
couldn't and couldn't stop it was so so
scary so
sending a lot of love to the heartland
is that
texas i don't think so two of texas
sorry
yeah okay well well also there they
there is like
big storms like in the surrounding area
it states heartland adjacent
yeah the heartland okay are you ready to
dive into the fast life stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
i am but i would be remiss i would be
devastated and i would even be
heartbroken if i didn't let you guys
know that today's episode
is brought to you by fab fit fun
fabfitfun spring box is centered around
the three
the theme grow forth supporting
self-care and self-growth in the new
season ahead
fabfitfun i'm on like my third box now
and it just really is a premium
experience every time i unbox because
you get so many
full-size products because i know there
are a lot of box subscription services
out there and you get like tiny little
things you get
samples and you might like the product
and you run out of it in a few days but
fabfitfun i got like huge mugs
a huge pack of um under eye gel masks
so all the products are full sizes which
mugs were stunning
stunning i like you know i've been into
tea because of downton abbey and those
mugs came at the perfect time
i also feel like on the show we always
talk about how important it is to treat
yourself and like buy gifts for yourself
and yeah
fun you get like a literal seasonal gift
delivered to yourself
to you from you but you don't know
what's in it but you also know it's
going to be great i feel like it's so
great for just like
your own self-care and their new box
which is themed grow forth it's all
about promoting that type of self-care
and they're passionate about showcasing
amazing women because 20 female founded
brands are in the spring box
this season where you can choose from a
wide variety of products when you order
um so they have beauty they have
lifestyle they have wellness they just
have a great range of products
i've gotten amazing things in the past
like beautiful scarves
mugs great lip glosses they really have
you covered
um and i'm just excited because spring
is is bound to be a good one
oh yeah um and if you want to sign up
for fabfitfun or get your spring box
today sign up now so you can snag
amazing products
like the mugs we were talking about or
anything else in any other wellness
beauty category
um but you have to use code toast if you
want to get the 10 off your first box
so the website is www.fabfitfun.com
code toast for ten dollars again that's
www.fabfitfun.com and the code is toast
for 10 off your first box love it
sign on treat yourself be fabulous be
fit and be fun
express yourself girl let it all
hang out okay are you ready for our
first story
some very happy news meghan markle and
prince harry announced they are
expecting
baby number two archie will be a big
brother
megan and harry are about to become a
family of four the duke and duchess of
sussex
are expecting their second child
together the couple announced on sunday
the baby will be the younger sibling to
the couple's son archie harrison who
turns two
on may 6th i did not know that archie
harrison was birthday buddies
with a snitch so first of all i loved
their announcement i thought this photo
was so gorgeous so elegant so royal
so stunning so happy i when i look at
this photo the song happiness by taylor
swift
plays in the background or for pharrell
cause i'm happy i belong if you
well i saw an interesting factoid about
this photo why it's historic
please share so this baby will be born
in america most likely but because his
father
he will also be eighth in line to the
throne so
this is the first human being ever who
could potentially be president of the
united states
and king or queen of england wow
so just something to think about when
you uh are thinking about your history
that is a really interesting factoid one
in which i did not know yeah i mean
and that's assuming that the child will
be born in the states i assume
i assume the child will be as they've
taken up residence here right
but i feel like this is like i wasn't
expecting them to make i wasn't i just
i like them like they have their child
like i wasn't expecting another baby
announcement i don't know why
and this was just a great wonderful
weekend happy bible news yes
very happy they announced their
pregnancy with the stunning black and
white photo that was taken remotely via
ipad
by their friend and long time
photographer mison harriman wow
the smiling and barefoot harry looks
lovingly at megan who cradles her bump
as she rests in her lap it's really a
really beautifully stunning picture
it'll be in textbooks it was taken on an
ipad just like this one
that's crazy okay take one of me and
theo like that maybe he'll look up at me
i know after this we should do a shoot
of you guys playing like that that's
beautiful
um just warning you guys the
construction is back hopefully you can't
hear it but just try and ignore it
because you know
this is new york everyone loves it
that's it
greatest city on earth i'm really happy
for megan and harry i feel like they're
when i saw this picture i'm like this is
the happy ending after mexi like this is
what all that was for
right but also she had announced that
she had a miscarriage over the summer
and so this is just a very happy
even happier news for them than you go
baby and
i'm very happy for them me too this is
great and a sickening they're like just
they make amazing photos like that photo
we always talk about
the blue uh dress and the rainbow
umbrella
the latest photo on our instagram
because claudia posted it i'm obsessed
with it they just have great
photo ops they really do they have great
kodak moments they do they do
well we also have a little more megan
and harry news because oprah is going to
sit down for an interview with prince
harry and meghan markle a 90-minute
special on cbs that airs on sunday march
7th it is being trumpeted as an intimate
conversation with the former royals
the statement reads that oprah will
speak with megan the duchess of sussex
in a wide-ranging interview covering
everything
from stepping into life as a royal
marriage motherhood
philanthropic work to how she's handling
life under intense public pressure
later the two will be joined by prince
harry as they speak about their move to
the u.s
and their future hopes and dreams for
their expanding family
well if anyone could do it it's oprah
and this will be really interesting i
feel like
no i'm done yeah given that with this
news it's actually crazy that we haven't
had this sooner right i was just gonna
say i feel like the story is played out
but they actually literally have not
spoken
it's just everyone else speaking for
them and even when they do speak it's
about other subjects whether it's their
podcast they're sharing other people's
stories like
i think it's going to be really great to
hear from them 90 minutes
cbs see you march 7. you know i will
certainly be
tuning in yeah so that's that's your
royal update for the day
yeah also a little better news i don't
know if you chose it but um
juni cortez and meghan trainor had their
baby no i didn't choose it that's so
happy so happy for them but our next
story
is a little more bed then news because
brandi redmond has given birth to her
third daughter
i didn't even know she was pregnant i
saw this on twitter i know that's part
of why i chose the story obviously i'm
so happy for her and her growing family
but the timing of this pregnancy is like
kind of perfect for her because
she is not pregnant yet on reproductive
dallas maybe we find out during this
season that she is and now
what's the headline she's given birth
she's given birth to her third
daughter but she is like she has four
kids she has four children now
well she they had another daughter yes
that's crazy
is she redheaded yes of course she is
her name is
brelynn mary redmond and they made the
announcement via people over the weekend
brandy said we are overjoyed with love
and beyond blessed to be welcoming our
little miracle
breelyn shares a birthday with her late
grandmother who we honor and miss very
much in case you forgot
um brandy's mother-in-law died in a car
crash in october 2020
where her daughter brinkley was also in
the car
she was unharmed it was a very scary
story that's crazy
yeah and they're they do the b names
brian brandy brook
bruin yeah it's cute bruno it's cute
it's just a good baba
oh so cute red hair that's yeah those
are crazy jeans they both have red hair
all their kids have red hair and they're
a sweet family and i
loved watching them adopt bruin and now
they have another babe
yeah and so by the time they film the
reunion
she won't even be pregnant anymore like
she will have already given birth
but we also it's just an interesting
timeline and one in which i think works
out for her
that she didn't have to work so much
yeah well also i find it so
interesting how like the women of dallas
the housewives are just all skewed so
much younger
because like in certain franchises like
nobody's had a baby like
on beverly hills or oh teddy but we were
she was the youngest
teddy was pregnant that's what it's
funny we had this conversation but i was
saying like nobody really has
it gets pregnant on housewives and you
were like rattling off all these
different
no but i mean like in atlanta too but i
meant no they have like porsche candy no
i'm saying in atlanta
they have recent pregnancies yeah i just
feel like the women of dallas are so
much younger than the women of beverly
hills atlanta
and new york like we've we've never had
a pregnant new york housewife yeah
so but all the women of dallas are so
young i feel like brandy won't be the
last one to be pregnant like
it's possible because they're all super
young and like still
growing their families yes but i'm happy
for her i'm happy for her too
speaking of someone else i'm happy for
i'm excited for this story for you vegan
tick tock star tabitha brown is writing
an inspirational book
and a cookbook oh she said we'll be
purchasing a black
inspirational book i'm not vegan but the
inspirational book is called feeding the
soul
because it's my business oh that's so
funny
people can reveal exclusively the new
book will be published by william morrow
on september 28th and her own cookbook
will
follow she also uh needs a food network
show like i don't know whatever everyone
is doing
yes like taking their damn time she's
such a queen
but this is such great book news which
we love to see we
love to see news that makes sense and
also digital stars foraying into the
traditional world
in a way that is seamless yeah i agree
she's a star i love her she's just one
of those people
who radiates positivity on her platform
and those are the people we should be
lifting up
and giving opportunities to and i just
love her and i'm so happy for her
she's hysterical yes she said i
literally wake up and pinch myself at
the thought of my life today versus four
years ago right then i hear my daddy's
voice in my ear saying you only live
once but if you live it right once is
enough
she says i couldn't agree more living in
my truth is enough and it's the best
feeling ever
sharing that with the world in my book
is such a blessing and my hope is that
readers will take the same feeling away
after reading it
yeah no i think a self-help book from
her obviously the cookbook is like the
natural
you know next step but i'm not vegan so
and i don't really use cookbooks but i
would
definitely read a self-help book or just
like an inspirational inspirational
is what it's being um targeted so i
don't know if
it categorizes self-help sorry i thought
you said self-help inspirational
but that's just great because she really
is an inspiration and i
love her yes i love that and some more
digital news that i'm looking forward to
getting your opinion on rebecca minkoff
is joining only fans for new york
fashion week engagement
she is um planning to use only fans to
interact with her consumers during new
york fashion week the subscription-based
platform which allows content creators
to directly connect with their audience
has become quite notorious for its
democratization of the sex work industry
though its use extends far beyond the
fashion designer will use her only fan's
profile
to share exclusive style content ahead
of her new york fashion week show on
february 16th
fashion week is still happening who knew
now available to follow minkov's profile
features never before seen video content
of past fashion week events
and allows a glimpse into the life of
the designer she will also use the
platform
to share her entrepreneurial journey
with her audience expressing her story
as a female founder within the fashion
industry so it she's using only fans you
know as the subscription
based content platform that it is
you know and i think what people would
say is an interesting use of the
platform for a traditional
mainstream fashion designer yeah i mean
like part like i just want to roll my
eyes at this story because
i feel like when rebecca minkoff is
making news it's because i feel like
she's
she's really smart and she has like a
young smart team around her and they're
always looking for
forward-thinking ways to elevate their
brand but they're never going to do that
like with their clothes like you know
what i mean like
it's just like at this point it's like
click baity type news things like cool
like is any does anyone care
no i don't care i do think it's
interesting like i wonder if it's the
sort of thing where it's like this is
the first of
many brands that now take to only fans
just like you know when snapchat came on
the scene and then brands went to
snapchat
and i don't know if it's gonna happen
that way
but i think i think it's interesting for
only fans which has become
like which whose growth has just been
exponential
yeah no and there it definitely is a
space out there on only fans for content
that isn't
you know sexual but that's what people
are going the platform for and i don't
see it becoming like a a patreon
for people who would just have any type
of content like it's just been marketed
too well as what it is you know yeah no
it does remind me of patreon and then i
was like should we be on only fans no
and then i'm just like why
everyone who's trying to like start and
only fans just get on patreon it's such
a great platform yeah i guess the
difference is one the way that it's
branded but also
only fans is just photos and videos so
like we do audio and therefore we
actually couldn't do what we do on only
fans got it because i thought about it i
was like
should we be on only five right i mean i
could start and only fans and make
literally four million dollars a month
with these titties but
i'll save that for my husband nice well
and theo
oh do are you ready for our fifth and
final story a little
biz news yeah
bumble's 31 year old ceo becomes a
female billionaire
a company catering to women and led by
women has made its 31 year old female
founder a billionaire wilton
whitney wolf heard's steak in bumble is
now valued at 1.5 billion dollars
after its ipo last week
she um i saw so
they went public they went public this
is big news because she's
one of the rare female billionaires
according to forbes she's the youngest
self-made female billionaire
you know which is a jab at kai right
even though they're they're the ones
hung up on this word
selfie gave that they gave it to kylie
then they took it away and they gave it
to it
and it's like all these articles i'm
reading about it's like no one else is
hung up on self-made
except for forbes right no like these to
come down he's like
young female billionaires and we're
gonna pit them against each other it's
sick
disgusting disgusting i just do think
it's a big deal that a dating app went
public you know
yeah well bumble has become obviously
you know we all know
just this huge even like media company
at this point
and they went publicly actually the
shares performed
even like better than what they started
at and i think it was like a
value to like i don't want to get it
wrong but multiple billions
that's great i mean we love female
founded entrepreneurship billionaires
and
here's to you know the next two female
billionaires
yes and bumble is one of the one of
three female founded firms to ipo in the
past year oh wow
making it you know an even bigger deal
well that's fabulous i'm so happy for
them congratulations to everyone and
it's a great day to be a woman a female
businesswoman
um let's get into our tv recap segment
before this construction makes me
literally go outside and kill someone um
and the
bachelor segment is brought to you by
noom theo you okay
you want to know about noom okay let me
tell you think about everything you've
ever learned about getting healthy
there's a lot of contradictory
information out there and things like
that old fashioned food pyramid aren't
much help
if you have you ever gotten questionable
food advice it's not about what you ate
it's about how you eat in general and
numa is going to teach you about your
eating your cravings and how to build
new habits
so you can ditch your misconceptions and
get smart food and get smart about the
food and the choices you make
based in psychology noom teaches you how
to eat so you can accomplish your
personal health goals and stick to them
long term
because you don't need rules to lose
weight you need knowledge with nume you
pick the health goals that are right for
you and noon personalizes a weight loss
program to help your aspirations become
reality
so if you have specific goals that you
want to work on with noom you can get
help with eating better
having more energy feeling good about
yourself improved sense of self-worth
self-worth and the program is super easy
and convenient
so you can learn more about what you're
eating you can ease into it with just 10
minutes a day
and they're very empathetic because you
you know you go off the path
you you [__] up a little bit no worries
noom doesn't judge and you can get right
back on
asap noon's cognitive behavioral
approach means you're not just losing
weight but you're building the habits
you need to keep it off
noom is forgiving because you're human
so if you go off track you'll get back
on track tomorrow
there's a science to getting healthier
and it's called new sign up for your
trial today at noomnom.com
toast learn how to eat again with noom
sign up for your trial today at noom.com
toast ready to learn how to live
healthier sign up for noom today
at noom.com toast
love it okay the bachelor heather part
two her and her minivan were sadly
escorted out
but not before making some waves amongst
this group of women who i've
grown to really dislike 100 it's weird
like last week we were like heather what
are you doing here like we were all so
hard on heather and then this week's
episode started and all of a sudden i'm
team heather within one minute yeah the
way that the women treated her was
so disgusting disgusting and it's like
they've learned nothing you either
die the um here where you live long
enough to see yourself become the
villain
and that is all of these women yep and
you know what made me extremely turnt on
every single one of them
me too but let me just say we were
talking last week about how some of the
girls are definitely
when they did this whole like exposing
of the bullies some of the girls got
away with like being hardcore bullies
and not getting you know sent home like
anna and victoria and that was
serena and that was also kit
i know everyone likes her and i do too
but she was a bully in the beginning
and then in last night's episode she was
like just go home [__] and i'm like oh
my god like
she said that you know i know i thought
it was a crazy thing to do again
was like being so insecure and then also
being such an
extra [__] by the way because and we
have to be clear it's
we're talking about serena c because
yeah
serena c like wouldn't even look at
heather yeah she spoke to her she was
turned towards the girls and talking
[__] at least say to someone's
face yeah no she was being so insecure
they all were and you know who else who
i really liked
and the second she started being mean to
heather i'm like oh man you're so
lame piper piper oh my god she was
acting so insecure
yes and it was i mean all of them were
acting
in a way that made me dislike all of
them and just completely think of them
differently because
in any situation where there's bullying
there's always going to be like the
vocal bullies obviously
and those people you know in the past it
was anna victoria
even serena c and it's like they're
obviously the worst but then there's
also the people
who laugh yeah and then there's also the
people who don't you when they do
nothing yeah
and they are all bullies in my book
there was not one
katie who said i died i was missing her
and it's
very clear that heather m is
a nervous shy girl and i feel like i
understand someone came in and you're
pissed but when she came up to you guys
couldn't have been like sweeter and more
polite and started crying
and and nervous like let it go and then
serena says
can you go away and cry in your
interview that was so mean i don't know
how
you could literally let someone cry in
front of you and at the end of the day i
i empathize like it is frustrating
to be in this journey and then someone
else comes but trust me
matt was never letting this girl stay
they're going to hometowns next week
it wasn't even in the realm of
possibility so before you get all
clamped
and bent out of shape why don't you see
what matt does first you know who was so
mean and i was so upset with her oh
it didn't work out on colton season so
now you're trying this no
justenya my respect for dyssenia went
all the way down and i really realized
last night
you know she had already served her
purpose and that was to have the
confrontation with mj
and her presence was no longer needed
because her and matt were literal
strangers when they were sitting on a
date i'm like these two people have
never met each other in their entire
lives
and she was she ruined all the
credibility i
i gave to her for standing up to the
bullies and like holding her ground
i have lost all respect for her now i'm
like maybe mj was right
hundred percent i don't know everything
i was so disappointed like where did
these girls get off and also so a couple
of the girls who were
um being mean were the ones who were
bullied as for being
the new girls yep so it's like don't you
know how it feels
it's so lame and i was just like really
hating every single person on television
i can't remember a season of the
bachelor where the mean girl like
bullying
was this bad flagrant widespread
widespread like
it really like i don't care what happens
like these girls i'm
mean girls i'm writing them off and
they're like the girls we're talking
about are not even real
like i feel like the girls who could win
are not even involved in this drama like
we haven't even brought up
grace it's the girls who are most
insecure in their relationship with matt
who are most threatened by heather
now i want to say maybe it's just
because i'm already convinced that
rachel kirk connell wins
but i felt like last night was the first
episode where i saw matt treat one girl
differently than the other like he made
it more clear that he had feelings for
rachel than he did for anyone else
yeah and i think first of all i love
aloe blacc and i love that song and that
was just like an amazing like extra date
yes um but i and
i'm just like convinced that rachel wins
given everything that went on this week
and now here and how the franchise like
weirdly protected her
it's weird to watch last night's episode
when so much went on in the bachelor
world this past week yes and it's clear
that not one edit was made to the show
not that it necessarily should have been
but it's like
it's really these shows can't keep up
with the pace of the world around them
and that was so apparent last night like
every like there's this whole
conversation we know so much now yeah
and there was just there was
nothing addressed yeah but not but how
what could they have even really done
i'm not even sure what i was looking for
other than the fact that like
it just felt like whenever this was
filmed was so long ago compared to the
how many things happened this week yeah
and we didn't make it a story but there
was a huge update in bachelor nation
where after apologizing once i think
people were still really upset with
chris harrison
um based on his interview with rachel
lindsay and not only did rachel lindsey
announce on her podcast higher learning
that she will not be
renewing her contract with the bachelor
franchise i watched it it was
really um she just said like i'm
exhausted and i feel like that's what
everyone thinks like rachel lindsay must
be so tired and she is yeah
so what was she doing with bachelor
franchise just
that podcast podcast and then i think
you have a contract like
you if they like for the if the next
bachelorette they need someone to come
talk like got it once you're in contract
like you do things with them you show up
at after the final rows they're all
these weird things
so she's not going to be doing bachelor
happy hour i don't think so wow
and she just said i and i love the
platform that it's given me like she she
said i have so much respect and i
appreciate so much like
all the opportunities i've been given
after going on the bachelor and
i know that like i've kind of bared this
burden and as much as i want to continue
to like educate
it's exhausting and like i'm just she
said she's tired and i totally respected
that
and then after that chris harrison
released another statement
saying he's going to be taking some time
away from the franchise and will not be
filming after the final rose
to me it really seemed like he'll
literally be back next season he just
won't do after the final rose
which i know a lot of people were
calling for him to be canceled and like
fired but i think this is like kind of
cowardly like
the whole after the final row special
there's gonna be a huge segment on
rachel and on this conversation like
chris should be there and have that
conversation because he said he's
committed
to you know getting more educated on a
profound level and i actually feel like
being there for this conversation with
rachel
could be helpful to you in that process
of education
but yeah he doesn't want to overshadow
like it's rachel and matt's story
i think i don't know yes but he also
can't be the one to have the
conversation
they need another host to interview
rachel and to interview
chris yes and they definitely need
another host to do like you know
after the final rose duties which is
like you know happy couple updates and
it's a really huge job hosting the
teleprompter we've been there like it is
a production
the clapping it's not anything just like
an average podcaster can do because a
lot of people are suggesting like
people from the franchise like mike
johnson and well i love mike johnson
you have to be a trained host like we
have been to one of those uh
after the final rows and they are like a
legit television clap stand teleprompter
it's a lot of work and it's not just
anything anyone from the franchise can
do
no and i don't even know if it makes
sense to have like someone who is like a
former contestant i feel like maybe abc
should tap into
their hosting like they have a million
shows
yeah and like happy times on staff
yeah what oh the view is on abc but i
don't think any of those women are
interested in talking to the bachelor
yeah but you know i think i don't know
what the plan is it'll be interesting to
see but i think that
finding a host who can have this
conversation like is just something that
abc should have in there
yeah i mean i do think that chris
harrison will be fine like i don't think
he's going to be fired i think he's very
very close with mike fleiss
and this is just i do think it's like pr
and i think he's probably relieved to
not have to have this uncomfortable
conversation with rachel and matt
because if rachel is the winner and i
really believe that she is
not only is there so much to talk to her
about but her being engaged to a black
man like adds a whole
other level of conversation and so
i can just i feel like chris harrison
like took like it's a cop
out i really feel that way you don't
think that it's also
in for the people who are calling for
him to not
yeah no i mean i don't believe in cancer
culture like i don't believe in like
someone like i don't know i don't know i
just think like if he
like he released two statements but why
don't you
go on tv and let's talk like it's just
kind of like
like but he might still do that i don't
know what he has planned but he could
still do that and it'd just not be after
the final rose because
that's true he at after the final rose
he's meant to be the host and at this
point like he can't host this season
impartially you're so much a part of the
conversation yeah you're right you're
right but yeah yeah yeah
that's fair so
um but back to the episode a million
people went home six more people
kid went home abigail got sent home a
lot of people were up in arms about it
um and as much as i'd like to abigail i
don't think matt did her wrong in any
way they literally haven't spent more
than five minutes together since the
first night right
and she held on to that no but like
right
this season more than ever and also
given like everything that's happening
off the show i'm just like these
producers like
it's just exposing them like she got the
first impression rose
why did she never get a one on one day
can someone answer me that it's so
inconsistent
it and we know that the producers choose
the dates they choose everything like
really yeah i mean and people were upset
because
they loved her but i i don't really feel
like i ever saw a connection between her
and matt even when she got the one on
one rose i don't think
i'm sorry not one-on-one the first
impression rose i don't think it was
because matt was so
you know in love with her immediately
and they had a connection i think it was
because he really respected
how much she opened up to him more so
than anyone and that made her stand out
so
i never thought she was a real contender
for his heart i don't but she never got
a chance to be
right because she never had a date like
yeah i forgot about her the night one no
one there's not that much that's going
to happen but the person who gets the
first date all of a sudden becomes a
real contender
everyone who gets a date is a real they
just never gave her a chance yeah
and serena had a one-on-one and it went
fine even though she was like
uncomfortable with the tantric thing and
i do feel like as a society
we're we are beyond those types of dates
i agree and again it was like
on the producers like why are these
dates like this is
that's very intimate for like a new
couple and i think it's
funny and it's not it's not i can
imagine it's uncomfortable it was like
even with claire's season when we had
all of those inappropriate dates it's
like
it's a reflection on the show yeah and
it's like you guys do not even see what
you
what you're doing what you're doing it's
so awkward and it's just like read the
room
it's 20 21 like we're not doing that
anymore yeah um but she got the rose
jacenya did not get the rose she went
home kit decided to send herself home
she'd had enough she got her instagram
followers she didn't want to go home and
you know
cynthia rowley was like you can go on
the show but i'm nothing to do
you know i'm not filming so like she do
what you need she couldn't have done
hometown so like the second she realized
like oh [__] i might be making it to
hometowns like
gotta go i'm a long-term investment she
tried first to like
do her long-term investment he was like
i'll invest yeah no he was like no i'm
down i was like oh [__]
and then she was like yeah i'm shorting
the stock but of all the people i was
interested in seeing their life at back
home
kit was the oldest we're not seeing
anyone's life back home the families are
coming tonight
right you know right right right right
yes
just like last season too right okay so
six people went home
jacenya kit um
two from the rose ceremony chelsea and
serena i was sad to see chelsea go yeah
i think her and matt had a real
connection serena and matt never spoke
he was like you're still here bye
she went um and then towards the end oh
piper went home yes which was shocking
because
they just had a great date yeah and um
when it was between him and michelle
michelle
piper sorry piper and michelle it was
the only
michelle was the only girl left who was
what from the second wave right yes but
she had the first date
no she's just known matt for so much
less time i thought for sure piper was
going to get it i was actually really
shocked
matt and michelle have a really great
connection i think that
she even might win yeah if if this week
hadn't happened the way that it did i
would think that michelle
could potentially win yeah no i mean
rachel is so obviously the winner which
makes me really sad because
and we haven't even brought her up
that's how irrelevant she is but like
brie
is the queen of my heart like i when she
was standing at the rose ceremony just
like
i never saw someone so beautiful in my
entire life like i was shocked her skin
her hair like it was just
stunning and i'm like how is this girl
not the winner and i know
she hasn't gotten a lot of air time and
i think she's kind of quiet but like
brief her bachelorette
i know well i think out of the four
women i think
we'll get our bachelorette from one of
these from one of these women well they
know it's not rachel
connell i think it could be um
she's left serena p oh yeah i forgot
about her
brie michelle rachel i think michelle
could be our bachelorette
i think she could too but i love brie
cause people are also saying like
abigail for bachelorette
katie for bachelorette no but i don't i
think that if they were going to be it
would have already been announced to
drum up
some excitement for the next season and
in order to be
the bachelorette from a previous season
like you have to have your heart broken
and like
matt didn't know abigail and matt didn't
know katie like
there was no love story there they're
not heartbroken really like they were
just
girls on the bachelor crying do you know
what i mean yeah no i think there's no
redemption
story there i think katie has a chance i
think she's in the running i don't think
they've made their decisions yet i think
they want to see how the rest of the
season plays out who becomes like a fan
favorite
you know every time someone gets
eliminated everyone on twitter is like
blank for bachelorette yeah that's so
true these people haven't been
eliminated yet so there's no rallying
cry for them
there's no campaign yes that's
interesting yeah
but i was glad like because things have
moved so slow last night we literally
went from 11 girls to four like it was
so great when they were talking about
like hometowns hometowns like what are
you guys talking about there's so many
thousand of you
right no i was really grateful for all
the girls who went home there's always
that one episode in the season where
it's like they just
clean house yeah like guillotine like
and
like a clean break and i was grateful
like to be whittled down to four
yes like i think he has really a strong
group
i think that it'll be an interesting
rest of the season i don't know
i mean it seems silly almost to be like
giving a [__]
about this stuff when so much more
interesting conversations are being had
in real time about chris harrison rachel
corconell and when they both came on
screen i like felt so awkward i'm like i
know so much about you like
why are you talking to me about
something random like let's talk about
something real
you know yeah so i'm i'm actually
looking forward to the aftermath of the
season
after the final rose the finale maybe
maybe they're filming now
filming rachel and matt i don't know
like for the after the final
maybe i don't know like i'm just curious
there's a lot of different roads they
could take i hope they don't
like drop the ball yeah
i i it'll be interesting to see what
they do they have their work cut out for
them
yeah but other than that it was fine
everything's boring and i was just like
so bored
also i'm so bored truly and um
we just had the bachelorette now we have
the bachelor when do we get the break
again like i'm really needing the break
i'm cause now
every time in in the calendar year we
get like three seasons of the bachelor
and at one point i get fed up and i'm
like actually reaching that point
yeah i'm i'm there it's just like not a
good show
no it's not a good show at all i think a
lot of people are really reaching that
point
okay but it always feels like every year
i'm like this is it like this isn't
everyone's gonna stop watching and
they're like
nobody stops i know we shall stop to get
there yeah we tried that we honestly did
there we have it
where we didn't recap becca for hannah
brown yeah yeah yeah
and now here we are again here we are um
so that's our show that is our show
make sure to watch our toast movie of
the week which is rogers and
hammerstein's cinderella
starring brandi and whitney houston
available to stream for free on disney
plus so use your disney plus login or
steal someone else's
also next time you see us tomorrow merch
will already be available so set your
alarms 10 a.m eastern time
shopmorningtoes.com how you learn in
redheads merch
coming at you 10 a.m eastern that is 7
p.m no
7 a.m pacific so just figure it out
have a great day you guys we'll see you
on wednesday for home day thank you so
much for listening to the morning just
the millennium morning show we deliver
the best live stories that you need to
know every monday friday on youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found
so wherever you find your podcast find
us the more you chose to leave a five
star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you have
a great day
[Music]
bye
you